[Music]
you
welcome back to this lecture on problem
solving and this is the third part
lecture and problem solving it's a
continuation from the first two parts
that we did know in the first part of
problem solving lecture that we did we
looked at what is a problem and we
defined definition of what problem
solving looks like
so basically problem solving is higher
order cognitive function a higher of
cognitive process which starts after the
basic ugly processes of perception
attention learning memory has taken
place and so what problem solving
involves is to solve problems that have
been or to solve those mysteries which
have been generated through the other
cognitive processes so basically making
meaning of those mental representations
which have been made through the other
processes now on the first lecture we
also looked at what are the different
types of problems which exist so what
are the nature of problem solving and
what are the approaches that we use in
problem solving and so we looked at two
basic approaches to problem solving in
the first lecture the first was the
behavioral approach where we looked at
things like something called the law of
effect where we looked at how behavior
is conceived problem solving and so what
behavior is tend to say is that problem
solving is basically process where
number of acts are done a number of
trial and errors are done and these
trial and errors then leads to solution
and so problem solving is basically
understanding these assists are making
associations between the correct act
leading to the correct solution
so basically it sits in terms of the law
of effect which basically says that how
associations are made between the
correct act and the correct solution or
the correct output so that's that's what
problem-solving is all about
and we define Skinner's idea of how he
used cats and and understood
problem-solving as a trial and error
process and what he said is
problem-solving is all about generating
solutions by doing an act over and over
again and then finding the right
solution to it now the second view of
problem-solving was the guest artist
view which did not support what behavior
is said in terms of what problem-solving
is what they supported or what they went
ahead and looked at is problem-solving
is more of reorganization of the mental
representations which are created by the
lower quality process now when I say
lower cognitive process and higher
cognitive process we look into all those
cognitive process or we classify all
those cognitive processes
it starts with perception attention
learning problem and language and then
memory all those processes are called
lower cognitive process because these
pregnant cognitive processes may eevee
presentations so they look at the
problem they look at any any kind of
information which is impinging on a
neural system and they make mental
representations higher art of cognitive
processes are problem-solving reasoning
judgment and decision-making so these
generate solutions are these acquire
solution by manipulating the mental
representations so that's one
distinction which is there so basically
their guest artists believe that problem
solution arises by restructuring the
mental organizations were manipulating
the mental organizations and they
believe with eternity that there is
something called an inside the idea of
an insight which leads to mentally
present which
manipulations are mentally presentation
in the right order with generates the
solution and so this is the some of the
things that we say on the first lecture
in the second lecture we moved ahead of
it and we saw the various solutions that
exist to mental locks in problem solving
or hindrances in problem solving and so
there is have some of these solutions to
define an analogue he using problem
solving hindrance sorry using heuristics
as ways of problem solving or using the
algorithmic approach to solve problems
and so these are the some some of those
solutions issue a described in the
second lecture on problem solving of
what are the different ways of solving a
problem so we looked into those and we
did a comparison of these and we looked
at which is the better one and which is
the non better when we solve some of the
problems which is out there we also
looked at problem representations as
challenge to problem solving so what are
the factors which affect problem solving
so we saw some some basic challenges in
terms of how problems re presented and
some of the representation problems
basically what representation of a
problem means is at the very outset of
when a problem arises how do we encode
the problem and so we looked at those
processes also and some of the
challenges in prominent representation
is mental set or functional fixedness
and our stereotypes is something else
that we saw in the earlier classes on
problem solving beside that looking at
the challenges to problem solving in
terms of problem representation in terms
of the problem process we also looked at
problem solutions or problem solving as
a GPS device a general problem solver so
basically how humans solve problem and
how it is equivalent to computers or
machine solving problem so we looked at
that and we looked at the concept of GPS
the general problem solver and we looked
at how this solution really works or how
does the GPS really works
in addition we also looked at something
called expert versus nowise problem
solving we looked at how experts solve
problem and how no Isis solve problem
and what is the relation
to an expert problem solver and no ice
problem solver I saw that experts use a
number of strategies different
strategies the right combination of
strategies they also know when to use
what strategy and also know which
strategies work in comparison to what
NOAA and that is why they're called
experts they also tend to no problem
configurations but then being an expert
in problem solving also has its downside
and so the wrong side was some of the
obvious problems that expose don't tend
to know is they don't grapple or they
don't go ahead and register some of the
basic obvious factional problems since
experts are focused on to solving a
problem they are not aware of several
other problem facts which is out there
and so they tend to miss on some of the
facts in in terms of in comparison to no
vices so that is where we ended the last
section now given the fact that experts
are not able to conceive some or some of
the basic information or some of the
extra information additional information
which is given in problems it would
suggest that experts would be poor in
creativity they would not be able to
come up with creative solutions since
experts are at most of the time engaged
in coming up with solutions which exists
from coming up with true solutions of a
problem it could hinder creativity is
what the general notion would be out
there but as you look into it you will
find out that this is this is the
opposite of it it has been found out
that experts with with the very fact
that since they can come up with
solutions or come up with true solutions
they are very good in creativity so
let's discuss that here so in this
section what we will do is we look at
and look into what is creativity and we
look also into something called process
of creativity and look at how insight
helps into creativity and that is what
we'll be doing in this section so how do
we define creativity what is creativity
and how does creative products occur
what do you call creativity so is it and
it is is it that somebody has long hair
looks like an artist is a creative
person or somebody giving a solution
which is very different than what most
people would think about is a creative
solution what is a creative solution and
how do people attain creativity we often
define people in terms of creative
inputs in terms of this is a very
creative person and this is a very non
creative person kind of a thing and so
people who are called
nerds are known to be non creative in
comparison to people who are out to go
out of the way to come up with solutions
or think out of the box to come up with
solutions and we call these people as
non-trade so in this section we'll try
to see whether there are certain
personality dimensions to creativity and
what is creativity basically what kind
of solution to a problem is called
creative solution so basically well as
1926 he proposed that the process
leading up to a creative breakthrough
can be described in terms of four stages
so what he says is that creative
solutions or noble solutions of any
problem it it requires four steps it
goes through a process of four steps by
the way creativity is generally coming
up with solutions which are not only
more informative but it should be also
workable so creative solutions are those
solutions which are not only distinct it
shouldn't be that these that the
solution that you are coming up a
solution that you come up to a problem
is called creative when it is distinct
when it is different from the general
solutions which are already there at
hand it that's not the only definition
now that's not the only the inclusion of
what a creative solution is it should
also be informative it should also be
giving some kind of results it should be
result oriented so not only solutions
which are different are called noble
solutions are called creative solutions
the solutions in terms of novelty should
also vary in terms of in four
informativeness which give means that it
should give you more information it
should give you a wide variety of
information and it should not only solve
the problem it should solve the problem
in
we and that is not pretty solution sir
so then what Wallis's says is that there
are four processes in creativity or
there are four steps in creativity and
the how are these steps really related
so the first step in creativity is
something called the preparation stage
and in this particular stage the solver
gathers information and makes initial
attempts to solve a problem so given the
fact that a particular solution is given
to you a particular problem is given to
you for which you have to define a
solution at the first stage you will
look at all the information available
and this is the stage where problem
representation happens you look at the
problem at hand you understand what the
problem is try to understand what the
problem is gather basic informations or
basic bits of information from the
problem make mental representations of
it and then mentally represent or
mentally make a map of the problem at
hand
this is the preparation stage and you
come try to come up with initial
solutions to this say so in the
preparation stage this is basically
representation problem representation
stage where you look at a problem gather
basic information from problems at the
incubation stage the which is the next
stage what happens is a period of
productive inactivity happens so what
well in valid systems the first stage is
preparation where you gather all the
information from a problem and try to
get initial solutions then a second
stage comes in which is called the
incubation stage where a productive
inactivity happens so here people don't
respond or don't give up any solution it
is basically they are sitting and
thinking over it
that's that's that's the thing so in
terms of colas monkeys an experiment we
saw on the first lecture on problem
solving in terms of colas monkey this
four stages can be described so the
first stage when colas monkey monkeys
we're trying or attempting to get the
banana which was on the ceiling and they
were doing all kinds of fact was the
preparation stage where they were trying
to
find out what should be done or they
were trying all their maneuvers all
their knowledge into getting the bananas
the incubation stage was the stage where
most all the monkeys or the monkey today
trying for the banana this sat down and
they started thinking this is the
incubation stage we're productive in
inactivity of productivity happens a
period of relative inactivity happens
now what happens here is the the what
the monkeys were doing is they were
mentally restructuring the problem they
were looking at what was available they
looked at whatever is available to us in
in this particular cage and how to reach
the banana the third stage is called the
elimination stage a stage where the
solver arrives at the solution or a
critical insight this is the stage where
you first get the solution or the first
appearance of the solution happens so
after this is this incubation stage an
elimination stage happens in the
elimination stage whatever happens in
incubation all those mental processes
which happen during elimination they
release an insight or they give rise to
an inside they give rise to a probable
solutions and the four stage is a
verification stage in which the observer
or in which the person who solving a
problem takes up the solution or the
accept the insight which is developed
from the illumination stage or which
arises from the elimination stage and
verifies this solution or insight with
the problem and tries to come up with
the solution so basically then two
important stages in this step that is
the incubation and elimination so I
don't gain corresponding back to cold as
monkey the incubation stage was the
stage in which the monkeys are not doing
anything and just thinking or
restructuring the banana problem and the
elimination stage was the stage where
the monkey who was trying the heart he
came up with the solution that piling
the crates one over the other another
could be like a stair or it could give
us some kind of an height and that was
the elimination which he required and
the verification stage was the stage in
which he actually went ahead
piled all the crates which were
available into the cage stood into it
stood over over the last
and got to the banana so these are the
four stages which a well as defined
since these are the four strangers in
problems audition as he says appears now
Wallace theory has not been accepted in
in entirety however it has been pointed
out that to major this theory of malice
has not been taken out very nicely by
cognitive psychologists they they have
not accepted it and as a hands down
maneuver what they have done is but what
they believe is this these stages do
arise but from what well as the study
comes out is two important questions on
problem solving first what is the nature
of inside right so the solution that I
am talking about the solution that
wallahs talked about in the third stage
of elimination that insight what
cognitive psychologists wanted to do is
to find out what is this insight and
what is the nature of it what are the
barriers to it what are the various
factors to it or it doesn't improve or
does it decrease under certain
circumstances and what does it look like
so that kind of thing they were
interested in and second is a sudden
breakthrough in problem solving is a
reality can these be encouraged by a
period of incubation so the second thing
they wanted to know is that buying
increase in the incubation time can we
come up with more rigorous solutions or
more noble solutions right so we wanted
to establish this relationship between
the time spent in incubation and the
kind of insight through nature of inside
the kind of insight that I generate the
quality of the insight that I generate
and the time I spend in incubation they
wanted to establish a relation between
that they wanted to understand if
increasing or decreasing the time of
incubation leads to and generation leads
to the more certainty of generation of
the insight which further solves of the
problem so these are the two questions
that most kinetic psychologists
generated from Wallace's study so
basically then what is an insight let's
look at what an insight is so insight
involves basically making this
realization that a problem solution
occurs and what was the key idea needed
for that solution and the problem with
inside is that theories believe that
problem solving to be an incremental
process and not a sudden realization so
the idea that insight leads to problem
solving is the fact that this insight
which solves a problem comes out all of
a sudden right and so what most theories
believe is that this kind of realization
of all of a sudden of a solution does
not exist rather what most cognitive
psychologists talk about the theorists
believe is that solution to problem
comes by trying over and over again or
doing something called and trial and
error so problem solving is more or less
like come at doing acts towards
attaining the final goal or incremental
acts or incremental behaviors which
successfully leads to the final goal
another problem lies with the clear
definition and non experimental proof or
the existence of inside the gestalt
psychologists so guest stars were the
first people who came up with the idea
of what an insight it and they said that
this insight is basically comes out by
restructuring of the mental
representations which are made of the
problem and so the non-existence of
experimental proof of this insight is
another problem which exists outside so
basically then the idea is that this
insight has to be tested and so there
are several attempts which have been
done to test what is the nature of this
inside and whether the inside generates
from this kind of restructuring whether
this this and so on also the fact that
and whether this insight is suddenly
nature is it comes as it comes suddenly
or does this insight that we talked
about which is the problem solution of a
problem does it come by mentally not by
material cheering the problem or
spending a time of incubation out there
but it's how does it occur and they
believe that it occurs through this
incremental process of problem solving
or in in
mental problem solving in a step-by-step
problem-solving process so Gil hi and
Murphy in 2005 they made an observation
that even if insight was a reality it
could not be applied to all types of
problems so they believe that there are
even if the fact that in the period of
incubation exist and even if the fact
that this period of incubation leads to
a period of elimination which generates
something called inside which is
probable solution to a problem they
believe that there are problems in this
world which can never be solved by an
insight and this type of insight doesn't
work for all type of problems and they
pointed out that there are two different
kinds of problems which exists in this
world
one is called the insightful problem the
other is called the anon insightful
problem so this is the definition or
this is the classification of Gillihan
Murphy now what Gillihan Murphy says
that the non insightful problems are
those they are likely solved by
incremental process of problem solving
and they require analytical step-by-step
processing so what Gillihan Murphy says
is the non insightful problems are those
problems which are which are analog
e-base which are reasoning related
problems which are mathematical proof
problems and these problems will not be
solved or cannot be solved through this
sudden realization or this sudden
insight and what they require for
solution is trial and error they realize
that or they predict that non insightful
problems the solution to those kind of
problems arise from incremental working
towards or incremental efforts towards
arriving at the final solution it is
like the GPS problem solver and so what
we tend to do is to solve a larger
problem we keep on solving the problem
and each time improving on to it and
then are changing the final solution in
comparison there is something called
insightful problems are those with
solutions appear suddenly and so
what gilma and Murphy says is that the
fact that non insightful problems are
not the only thing which is out there
there are certain things called
insightful problems also and so certain
problems are exist which basically give
solutions or which in which solutions
are occur or solutions come up but
certainly all of a sudden and you don't
really have to do incremental processing
or if you don't have to do incremental
step-by-step processing of the problem
so how does insight help in
problem-solving what is the way in which
insight actually leads to problem
solving so there are two key assumptions
of how in insight actually leads to
solving of a problem and the first is
that it involves a mistaken assumption
that once removed will clear the way to
successful problem-solving and so what
it is believed is that insight as a
problem solution works in this way it
makes two assumption first there is a
problem there is an inherent problem in
insightful problem solutions arise with
the fact that there is some kind of a
mistaken assumption to start with so
people have started with some kind of a
mistaken representation of mistaken
assumption and when this mistaken
assumption is or taken away the solution
appears suddenly and so what inside
tends to do is that it remove this
mistaken assumption right and so what
they believe is that sometimes our
problems will not get solved because
there is a problem with the assumption
itself people assume in certain ways
people assume certain kind of facts or
people use some kind of facts for
problem representation which has a
mistaken identity and with this mistaken
identity is removed in some way or is is
made aware people are made aware of this
mistaken assumption in some way and when
they remove this the solution occurs so
this is the first way in which insight
helps you to solve problem and the
second is that the solver
is with the solution the solver is hit
with the solution
suddenly and that was termed as I
and the second fact the second key
assumption in insightful problem-solving
is the fact that the solver who solving
the problem he suddenly gets this
realization that the solution appears
and this sudden realization is called a
experience so this is that part in which
it's believed that the sudden sudden
realization of solution happens so
basically two assumptions in the
insightful problem-solving the first
assumption is the fact that the solver
there understands of mistaken identity
or understandably a mistaken assumption
which he used for creating the problem
and as soon as he understands that this
mistaken identity is removed or replaced
a solution appears and the second that
this solution which appears to the
solver in the elimination stage of
problem solving it happens suddenly it
doesn't happen over a period of time
over an incremental time but it appears
suddenly to the solver is suddenly the
restructuring of whatever the process
whether it is mental restructuring or
mental manipulation and mental
representations due to that a sudden
realization happens so it has to be
sudden it has to be out of the blue and
only then this is called the eye
experience and these leads to the
solutions of problems so let's look at
two in non insightful problems and two
non insightful problems and let's see
what is the whether the the fact that we
have Delta till now in terms of mistaken
identity and in term terms are non
mistaken identity and whether there is a
difference between insightful and non
insightful problems so I will give you
one minute to basically go ahead and
look at these problems and arrive at the
solution and then I will further give
you the solutions of this so beginning
now I give you one minute time to look
at both these problems and arrive at a
solution right so I guess that you have
enough time you had enough time to look
at both these problems and are you aware
of the solution so in the first case the
solution is 59 days right because the
lilies are doubling every 24 hours and
so on the 59th day
we half the pound and the sixteenth day
since it is doubling so basically on the
sixteenth day there will be full of the
pawn will follow be full of lilies and
some mistaken assumption is what we tend
to do is very tend to create a
mathematical expression of it
remember met the representation problem
that we saw in in the first lecture
itself how the problem representation
creates problem solution interest
problem solution and that is what it is
so this realization itself that it is
doubling itself and so on the 59 day
when it doubles in the 60th day the lady
in the lake becomes completely covered
with the least so on the 59 day it will
become half so what we are doing is we
are having the process and so that's how
it actually goes I'm pretty sure that
you have also the answer to the second
one and the answer to the second one is
that he has to unwound the row so in sit
is half the distance so what he has to
do is unwound the rope and once you have
in one Wanda row once you find out that
the rope is composed of two strings
which are bound together right so most
of your ropes have these kind of
stringing together and so once you
unwound it it will become two pieces
they're back to back attach them and
then he can use it and so this is the
solution and so as I am pretty sure that
these are the solutions which has
appeared to you suddenly and so these
are called insightful problems now we
have two non insightful problems and
easy as you would require that in these
problems there is nothing called inside
like what you need to do so thirty
Seconds to read this problem please read
this problem and come up with a solution
and so as you would find out that both
these problems require to create
mathematical equations and once you
created mathematical equations so the
second problem is a permutation problem
and the second first problem is also
kind of a permutation problem so both of
you are familiar with the concepts of
computation and combination you will
find out that you have to create a
mathematical equation for solving these
problems and so the it cannot be done
through inside right and sudden
realization of the solution is not there
you have to create some kind of
mathematical expression for it solve for
that expressions all for both the X and
Y's and you come up with the solutions
and so this is the difference between
insightful and non insightful problem in
terms of insightful problem a
mathematical equation can be generated
or it you require to generate the
correct expression and then solve for
the expression and the solution comes in
or correct the understand the correct
representation in terms of combinations
or permutations and based on that arrive
at a solution where there is in your
insightful problem you don't have to do
that you just think of the problem and
then is there is one light bulb which
which appears on your head and that is
the solution
so the mistaken identity is the fact
that 60 is full so if it is doubling
that 59 will be half that kind of a
thing or the fact that these ropes are
intertwined together so if you break it
apart we can attach it end to end and
then can escape the prisoner can escape
the cell so these are the basic
solutions to both insightful and this is
the nature of insightful and insightful
non insightful problem so the idea of
removal of mistaken assumption which is
there in inside the problem now the
difficulty of insightful problem is that
they involve one key but a errant
proposal which leads for the kind of
problem that you are facing in solving a
problem right now one of the most
studied problem which presents this kind
of mistaken identity or which
leads you to assume this mistaken
identity and that further leads you to
non solution of this problem is called
the nine dot problem right so I'm going
to present to you something called the
nine dot problem and your job is to
basically solve it so basically what is
the nine dot problem you have to connect
all the dots with one continuous line so
these are continuous line and what you
have to do is to basically join all of
them with one continuous line and the
problem requires or the problem is made
in such a way that there is one or some
key and error relating perception or
assumptions and these key error
perceptions or relations basically
hinders you to solve the problem so
basically how do you connect all the
dots with one continuous line and as you
can see no matter how you try it's very
difficult now people who would have
solved it may have seen this problem
before and that is making them solve it
but other people they'll realize that
solution to this problem is not easy no
matter how what you do no matter which
configuration you look at basically
joining these dots with one line is not
possible this is the solution right and
so as you realize that this solution
exists and this solution is the only
solution to this particular problem so
you start from from here and then this
is how what you do this is what you do
this is I mean this is what you do and
then you come with the final solution
and this is what the solution is all
about right
so what prevents you from solving this
problem what is the mistaken identity
the mistaken identity that according to
Karen or Carlson three sources or
difficulty are evident in the nine dot
problem the three three different kinds
of problems can arise now generally
speaking the problem is the problem
which makes you not see the solution is
the fact that you want to create this or
you want to stay within this boundary
once people want to stay within this
boundary
or four or this idea of staying within
the boundary they will never be able to
solve it so in this as you see we
violated the idea of this boundary and
so we are able to solve it and so this
is the mistaken idea so Kershaw and
Olson they they basically suggest that
there are three sources of problem or
there are three basic sources which
leads to non solution on the nine dot
problem and what is it first the
perceptual factors relating to vestal
organization principle so guest law
organization principle says that this
mental representation most mental
representation have an organization
principle they are organized together
and these organization principles help
you into coming up with solutions so the
idea of similarity the idea of
perceptual similarity the idea of
figure-ground all those things leave you
to stay within the boundary stay within
the boundary of the line dot so these
are the dots that I'm looking at and so
most guests will again start perceptual
factors are staying within boundaries of
per se or perceptual organization lets
you stay within the boundary and once
you stay within the boundary you will
never be able to solve this problem you
have to think it in a different manner
you have to break this assumption of the
boundary conditions that it is a square
the idea that this is a square and these
dots which are out there actually form a
square you have to break away from that
and only then you can solve this problem
the second is called the process factors
they - information processing demands of
the problem now sense the problem is
presented in such a way it looks more or
less like a square and the demands of
the problem is in in terms of a
particular way of solving it a
particular demand is out there of
thinking in terms of this boundary
condition and solving it and the idea
that it should be a continuous line this
leads to that this basic facts leads you
to solving problem in a particular means
or thinking about the problem in a
particular way and so not able to solve
the problem and the third is the
knowledge factor our prior knowledge
dictates the fact that these kind of
solutions don't exist or these kind of
solutions cannot be done no matter how
you try to connect it in whatever way
it's not possible or if you even if you
try connecting it this way it is not
possible and so these prior knowledge or
this
prior mental set which is out there with
problem similar to this that creates the
problem in solving it so basically both
perceptual factors press process factors
and knowledge factors add up together
previous knowledge which you have about
solutions like this or problems like
this that hinders you solving the
problem so any or all of these factors
might come into play and prevent from
problem solving or the nine dot problem
the second thing that we saw is the our
experience the experience of sudden
insight or sudden fact that a solution
exists now another defining feature or
the insight experience in a certain
tangible feeling of discovery usually
described as the eye experience now this
the issue of what someone is thinking as
they relate to metacognition so this
idea of AI experience is related
somewhere to something called the
metacognition what is metacognition
it refers to a person's knowledge of
their own thought process so the idea of
this our experience of whether you come
up with this sudden AHA experience or
the sudden realization the solution is
there to test this we should be very
sure that people are able to monitor
their thoughts and that is called
metacognition so can people actually
monitor their thoughts while solving the
problem and to solve this particular
fact of whether people are able to
monitor their thoughts when they are
solving the problem matter of metcalfe
and why way they conducted something
called the warmth rating problem what is
the warmth rating problem now what they
did was they took two groups of people
for one group of people they gave an
insightful problem and the other group
of people they gave a non insightful
problem now both of them were given
something called the hot cold plate and
what is the hot hot cold plate they were
asked mostly as most of these people
were asked to monitor their thoughts or
to monitor the process of how they were
solving the problem and they were asked
to basically report to the experimenter
whenever they were approaching to the
problem so the more clothes they thought
they were so coming to the solution of
the problem the more
warmer they would say that they were
feeling so if you if doing something if
and an attempt to solve a problem leads
you to believe that you are nearer to
the solution you say and what I am one
degree moment two degree warm and three
degree warm and so on and so forth but
if you do not feel that you are closer
to the problem you say I am cold that is
what the people have to say so basically
the more closer you think you are to the
problem the more warmer you will say you
are and the more distinct you think you
are away from a problem the more colder
you would say you are so what could be
the output of this kind of a result you
would believe that in generally in terms
of non insightful problem people would
increase their mom's rating because with
number of attempts with number of the
solutions or a number of attempt at
making the solution they become closer
and closer to the problem and so the
warmth rating will be increasing that is
what the answer to this the experiment
was for insightful problem the hindrance
or the the typicality happened for the
insightful problems in insightful
problems it is believed that the
solution comes suddenly and so people
would mostly say that they are cold and
suddenly they will say that they are mom
as the intuition comes in or at the
elimination stage at the stage of
elimination where the insight is
generated from the second incubation
stage people will say higher degrees of
what this is not what happened and so as
expected that people will stay cold or
people will say they are cold for for a
longer period of time and suddenly they
will say that they are feeling very warm
and this is the generation of the
solution this is what did not happen and
so the from this warmth rating itself it
was very difficult to to say that the
sudden realization happens and so this
verification of the sudden realization
of I experienced that was sort of not
proved or disproved by this metruff and
why we experienced or met laughs and why
we could not find out any support for
this evidence now in insight is also
been taken
as an intuition right it's believed to
be an intuition so the issue of whether
inside problem-solving involves special
unconscious process suddenly
restructuring or the problem elements or
removal of sudden mistaken assumption
serious controversy in the problem
so basically is it intuition that leads
to this reason reconstruction of problem
and and there's this institution leads
to a solution and whether this insight
is the institution there is still
controversy in the problem that this
restructuring happens so this kind of
controversy still exists in the the
field whether insight and intuition are
the same thing and whether this
institution is intuition that people
talk about is exactly restructuring of
the problem another prop fact that we
saw in the beginning of this lecture was
whether incubation leads to insight
whether more time given to intuition
leads to insight so one of the more
controversial notion was within the
study of the problem of incubation the
idea that taking a break from problem
solving leads to quicker solution then
continuing effort so whether if I give
you more time to solve a problem or if
you spend more time in the incubation
stage whether it will guarantee a
solution or not whether that was being
tested and whether this is equivalent to
solving using continuous process of
solid solving a problem the ideas to
break is that brakes allow for the
elements to or the problem to beliefs
reorganize for unconscious process to
continue to work on the problem and this
unconscious is limited by conscious work
on the problem so the question was
whether allowing you more time how does
it leads to insight or how does it leads
to this insightful solution and the
solution which has been proposed is that
taking break from problems these two
more unconscious process and these
unconscious process leads to mental
restructuring or the problem and
providing the solution now to test this
it people were given this kind of a
these kind of problem let me see if you
can solve this problem so there are four
problems in given to yes to you in in in
front of you these are called rebuses by
the way rebus problems and can you find
a solution to this so 10 seconds to
basically find solutions
as you would see that the solution to
this problem is in the first case the
solution so no matter how much I time I
give you the the problem solving of
these cases if you are not seen these
rebuses before it is very difficult for
you to solve this problem and so giving
enough time giving more time is not
going to solve only the fact that if you
have dealt with these problems before
can you actually solve it and so as you
see the first box basically expresses
just between you and me that is what so
just is between you and me and that is
the solution I am pretty sure that you
are able to call the second one and the
second one says reading between the
lines so reading is the word reading is
between the lines and that is what it is
so the answer is e reading between the
lines that is the solution to it third
one I am pretty sure you have guessed by
now it says degrees below zero so these
are the degrees which are there and is a
below zero that is what it is are you
sure you're able to solve the last
problem the soft-rock no matter how much
time I give you it is not going to be
solved because there is a mistaken
assumption out there and it basically
says fly-by-night fly is by night or the
side of night and so these are the sorts
and so several terms have been done to
find out whether increasing the time
leads to solution dog incubation time
increasing of incubation time means to
correct solution it isn't founded that's
not what it is true
so then what kind of factors actually
leads to solution correct solutions and
Smith suggests that incubation effects
do occur but only under certain
circumstances so increasing time is
going to work as generating solutions
for insightful problems only under
certain conditions namely when a problem
is doable and when the solver is blocked
by some way from which the solution so
only under two conditions if a problem
can be solved only in though
stages you can be able to or even be
able to find our solution to problems
and the second is when the solver is
really blocked by some kind of an idea
so he's trying again and again and he's
blocked by some some kind of a problem
mistaken identity only then these
problems can be given more time into
incubation stage is going to solve it
but if the problem has no idea or is
represented the problem in a wrong way
or there is some other problem in
Durance to the problem solving it is not
going to work
so Smith offers a contextual view of
incubation which is basically the
encoding principle or encoding
specificity principle in Reverse what
does it really mean if you basically go
to encoding specificity principle it in
in terms of long term memory it
basically means that the more closer our
solution context is to the problem
context the easier the solution is in
terms of insightful problem-solving in
terms of using insight as a
problem-solving method a reverse is true
which means that the more diverse the
context the more time you give to people
and the more diverse the context in
solving problems the better the insight
is so insight as a solution to a problem
occurs only when you change the context
in the same context is that people will
be thinking in the same manner so if you
change the context the thinking change
is the restructuring of the problem of
how occurs or a new line of thinking
arrives and because of this new line of
thinking the solutions can be appeared
too and this is what Smith 1995 view of
contextual problem is all about so the
contextual view of incubation stage that
when problem solving is time the
solution will come more easily if there
is a contextual change and that's what I
was trying to tell you now what is
creativity
now creative individuals are able to
think outside the box what does it mean
to come up with new ideas views and old
problems in a fresh perspective and
connect seemingly disparate problem
solutions so these are those four people
who can come up with new ideas view old
problems from a new perspective and then
even with old problems they can connect
the old problem or think of the problem
in a new way so what is creativity the
experts they believe that creativity
generally agree that creative solutions
have two components
any creative solution any creativity has
two components to it one is called the
novelty and the other is called the
appropriateness now as I described at
the beginning of this chapter any
creative solution has to be new it
should not be a copy of the solution
which exists and it should be
appropriate in the sense that it should
give you enough information it should
give you appropriate information for a
solution only novelty is not going to
solve the creative insights so creative
solutions are novel different from
previous solutions and usually
unexpected the solution of creative
problem must also satisfy the
constraints of problem at hand that it
that is it must fulfill a need to be
sensible and useful so just coming up
with some novel solution to a problem is
not creativity creativity is also
appropriateness which means that it
should typically solve the problem in
the easiest possible manner an optimal
solution to be exact now one of the most
cited framework for describing and
investigating creativity was proposed by
Rhodes who suggested that creativity can
be informed by a focus of several
dimensions so basically what's wrote
says is that creativity can be mapped on
the basis of four dimensions or four
things which are out there and what are
these first things person for creativity
four things are important the first
thing is a person creativity to some
extent is related to the aspect of a
person or personality is believed that
creativity occurs for a certain kind of
personality and so what is this kind of
personality creative people are taught
to exhibit a number of personality trait
like they have broad interest they have
a number of they appreciate complexity
and they can tolerate ambiguity so
creative people not only are those
people who have just number of interests
out there but they have tolerance for
ambiguity which means that they can
tolerate ambiguous solutions or they can
tolerate ambiguous situations and they
love complex things out there right and
they have higher self-confidence and
they are risk-taking people so those
people who are risk aversive are never
creative people who are is taking a more
creative in nature so one of the factors
will define three
TVT or creative solutions or how you
come up with greatest solution is the
kind of person that you're using the
personality factors nor simply believes
that creativity is not always the
product of a particular comfortable
environment in fact creativity depends
on diverse and sets of life experience
so the more life experience you have the
more tolerable you are to be ambiguity
the more broad interest you have and the
more self-confidence you have and the
more risk-taking you are then you are
creative the second process or the
second factor in creativity is called
the process so creativity also refers to
specific set of processes which are
there to contradictory ideas about
cognitive processing in creativity has
been preferred one is called one view is
that it's a special process and
abilities and like the ability to
quickly restructure problem information
and connect seemingly remote
possibilities so basically one view of
creativity believes that creativity is a
special process and it is the ability to
restructure problem and how this
restructuring happens by connecting
seemingly remote probabilities so those
probabilities are those possibilities
which are not thought of before they are
brought in those answers which were not
thought of as an answer to a particular
problem they are thought and they are
included into the new solution that is
how creativity works and the another
view is that creative thinking is a
product of garden variety of cognitive
processes such as attention in memory
and this first so first view is
basically using those solutions which
are not there and restructuring problem
and taking those solutions which have
been given before but we somehow didn't
explain the solution using all of them
together and restructuring the problem
and forming a solution to it the second
view believed that creative solutions
are basically through higher cognitive
processes or different to increase in
different cognitive processes like
memory and attention so the more memory
and attention you have or the varied
kind of every intention processes that
you employ the more creative you will be
the creative cognitive approach Smith
2003 they argued that the answer
is probably that creative thinking can
be the result of either the two so
basically they believe that it is not
just restructuring which leads to
creativity it is also a different kind
of common are multiple cognitive
processes and all of both of them
combined together to actually generate
creativity and so stand back and
Davidson they cite three processes as
important in reaching creative insights
and what are these processes one is
called selective encoding the other is
called selective combination and third
is called selective comparison so these
three processes are and selectively
encoding information selectively
combining information in selectively
comparison of information leads to a
person to doing different cognitive acts
and then restructuring problems in a
different way and then also using those
solutions in a not been used before or
have been neglected before and coming up
with creative solutions the third factor
in creativity is called press it refers
to the notion that creative behavior
does not occur in vacuum rather there is
a subject to various external pressure
and contextual factor process so
basically the context and the external
environment has a lot of role to play
into creativity now creative acts are
also products of interpersonal
disciplinary and so-called social
cultural environments so it's believed
that it is not only that internal
factors cognitive process relates to
creativity
it is also diverse setting diverse kind
of factors which are out there so
different kind of social environment
different kind of interpersonal accel
exchanges all these contextual factors
these two creativity and the fourth
factor or the fourth part of this
creative in how creativity develop is
the product which refers to the outcome
yielded by the creative process be it a
painting poem design or a new technology
so what kind of autumn outcome that I'm
generating the analysis of creativity
from this perspective is a challenge as
its evaluation requires sometimes of
objective standard and so basically it
says that the kind of product that is
generated out of creativity
it also requires certain kind of
to evaluate it right and so basically
what it is that the kind of product that
is generate out of creativity that
requires certain evaluation standards a
different kind of evaluation standard
for it to be generated and so there are
different kind of creative out output it
could be in terms of the painting or it
could be in terms of mold process it
couldn't be in terms of an old product
and each of them will require a
different standard for evaluation or a
different kind of evaluation which is
out there now there is a taxonomy which
has been proposed for creative process
and products and this has been done by
titration 2004 they proposed a useful
scheme that imposes some order in the
desperate research into creativity so
nitrogen at creative insights as our
creativity works on two different
domains one is called the processing
mode and the other is called the gnomish
the knowledge domain so on two accesses
that which try to look at creative
processes what he says that any creative
product or any creative process can be
mapped on to two-dimensional space and
this two-dimensional space
has a dimension or something called
processing mode in which mode the
processing is being done of creative
solutions or in which mode then the the
creative solutions have been generated
and the second node is second domain is
called the knowledge domain or the
second axis on which creative products
is to be analyzed is called the
knowledge domain so in terms of
processing domain refers to whether
creativity insight is there is a result
of deliberate or if a full search or
whether it emerges spontaneously as an X
and expected flash of insight so in in
in terms of the processing mode in terms
of the processing mode access or the
processing mode dimension there are two
ways to look at creativity right
creativity can arise or creative
solutions can arise from a thought about
from a well thought about process by
using most of your memory into it or
using most of our cognitive process and
generating a solution or creative
solutions can occur suddenly after the
blue and you do not do enough cognitive
processing into it and so on this
dimension of the processing dimension
the dimension varies from a deliberate
effort full cognitive processing to a
sudden realization of the solution or a
sudden up coming of the solution on the
knowledge domain or basically on the
axis of knowledge domain on the on the
dimension or knowledge domain it refers
to the nature of the creative insight
whether it is characterized by more
cognitive or more emotional breakthrough
so basically what type of output it is
creating whether the output that the
creative solution is producing is more
cognitive in nature or more emotional in
nature and so basically there is this
kind of a table has been created and
it's very easy to understand this table
there is a two axis on to it on this
table one is the processing mode and one
is the knowledge domain so within the
processing mode you have the spontaneous
processing mode where is believed that
creative solution happens all of a
sudden or just a deliberate solution
mode in which you believe that creative
solutions occur from deliberately
thinking about it or doing efforts and
coming up with it in terms of the
knowledge domain in terms of the fact
that what kind of solution do what kind
of creative solution are we coming up
with there are two things it could be
more cognitive in nature which basically
means that it could be more thoughtful
in nature it could be more information
knowledgeable in nature or it could be
an emotional product or it could be an
emotional output that that is there and
so as you look into it a more cognitive
and more spontaneous idea or creativity
in in terms of more cognitive and more
spontaneous is cokecake you esteem of
what benzene ring so what happens is
although the solution came to kql in his
night sleep but he was thinking about
the solution for a longer period of time
and so it was more cognitive and more
spontaneous in terms of thinking the
deliberate mode was mapping the human
genome so people so people who created
this
a human genome they were working for
this over and over again and they were
doing deliberate efforts to solving this
and out of this deliberate efforts out
of this continuous effort to solving
this problem and using a lot of
knowledge a knowledgeable way of mapping
the human genome or creating the DNA
sequencing came up in terms of emotional
product
the van Gogh self-portrait is actually a
spontaneous output to it so all of a
sudden when God draw this idea of self
portrait or the idea of Mona Lisa which
is more emotional in nature and then it
creates it was created all of a sudden
but those insights which are generated
out of psychotherapy those emotional
insights or reason for emotional
problems which are created or which are
generated or which are evaluated in
terms of psychotherapy sessions are a
deliberate mode because the
psychotherapist has to work with the
person and he has to work backwards
right it is not suddenly spontaneously
this person will say that this is the
emotional problem that I have or this is
the problem which is the reason for all
the emotional hindrances that I have
been facing in my life what they will
say is that building up using a free
recall procedure that the
psychotherapists go step by step to to
zeroing in into that emotional fight or
that emotional discrepancy which leads
to problems now I have so I'll leave you
with certain problems which are out
there and some of these problems are are
insightful some of these firms are not
insightful and you can actually look
into it
so basically as you look into it this is
this is possible because a child could
have actually fallen out on the second
floor right and this this is possible
because the mother could have been the
surgeon so I'm just giving the dancer
this is most people know it and if you
are familiar with the same sense if
there is an episode which talks about
this candy base and how the Simpson
father
Homer Simpson he goes ahead and solved
this problem so I'll refer I'll give you
a hint
to look into it I think in season 26 or
24 they gave a solution to this and this
is possible because he was not having
the truck with him and so he can walk so
these are the same different number of
insightful problems a non insightful
problems out here which you have a
solution so what we did in this lecture
is we continued with what is inside we
try to explain you what is inside and I
also tried to include in introduce to
you what is creativity and then looked
at different kinds of how insight really
works into finding solution to problems
and what is the role that inside has
into solving problems then I went up and
explained what is creative creative
process and the four different parts of
the creative process and at the end of
it I explained to you that hierarchy
that taxonomy which basically goes ahead
and look at in in any creative product
and maps it into two domains or Maps it
into two 2-dimensional X's one
dimensional being in terms of the
knowledge domain so where it is going to
improve the creative product where it is
going to affect whether it is creating
knowledge or whether it is Khaimah
creating emotional support or emotional
output and in terms of the processing
mode whether on an effort was done to
create the solution or whether the
solution arrived on its own so this is
what we did in this / - day's lecture
and this is the last section on problem
solving so until we meet again thank you
[Music]
you